je pense qu'aujourd'hui une vraie
attendre des gens par rapport à la
nature à l'environnement
une vraie attente de ceux de se
confronter de se développer aussi de
rechercher de l' équilibre même même du
bien-être tout simplement à travers à
travers cette cette confrontation cette
capacité à se développer à trouver des
solutions soi même et c'est à quel que
soit son niveau mais c'est donc ça c'est
vraiment chouette
les risques qui sont quasiment toujours
les mêmes quand il ya de l'adrénaline
c'est l'euphorie de france
c'est ça paraît bête mais on va penser
altitude machin truc je pense que
appartement où je commence à me sentir
trop bien changé mais c'est c'est c'est
toujours pareil je me fais cette
réflexion tout le temps à partir du
moment où je suis trop bien je diminue
la vigilance et je vais peut-être faire
des trucs que j'arrête j'aurais pu
j'aurais pas dû quoi moi je suis portée
par ce que je vais y est enfin pas gagné
pas le record par la médaille parce que
je vais gagner
intérieurement en fait ça me paraît
tellement énorme par rapport à ce que je
ce que je ressens comme le à chaque fois
que que que
je discute pas on va perdre d'autant
plus avec ce à quoi on est vraiment dans
le bien être c'est un peu comme si on
était sur un coussin ses fins ou annuels
jouffa voilà on est on est on sent
détendu en fait donc
c'est d'étendre la fin ça va tellement
bien quoi c'est mais on est bien on est
détendu physiquement comme
psychologiquement ça que jamais je
réfléchis autant que 11 ans d'histoire
mais j'ai des idées je me fais peur
tellement gêné quoi je parle je vois des
trucs chez parce que je suis tellement
libéré que j'ai jamais été aussi pour
l'équipe
je reviens de se lever quelques minutes
et on agit aux magies cache donc à ce
moment-là je devais être à 5200 comme
une 300 mètres dans ces eaux là il est
un bon -30 degrés il devait être trois
quatre heures du matin de la nuit noire
et tout est là je vois le soleil qui
commence à se lever peut-être vers 4h30
cinq heures dans ses locaux et donc mais
c'est extraordinaire enfin c'est mais je
vais essayer de faire des photos et
surtout une vidéo une vidéo sympa donc
je sens mon petit appareil avec mais
avec mes gros gants en fait un stoner de
mettre relever en hurlant
voilà donc j'ai bien compris
d'éventration j'ai pas dis un peu et de
il ya peu il ya peu de souci il s'agit
bien compris la douleur j'ai pas compris
l'éventration air et j'ai eu mal et j'ai
cherché je peux pas résoudre ce problème
là quoi donc
mais je suis un endroit où il fait un
froid terrible je sais que je peux pas
rester tu peux pas rester à l'arrêt et
tout donc là tout de suite dans mon
analyse très vite je vais me à kebab
faute ans donc je vais ailleurs est un
ange est vraiment très très mal et je me
fait rejoindre par un coureur qui est
médecin kim ausculté et qu'il a vu que
effectivement j'avais une éventration il
fallait faire évacuer et je dis oui mais
oui mais oui
et sinon et donc diba posting vite à 4
heures en fait
en fait avec le doigt ils m'ont rentrée
intestin est un micro troupes et le
doigt qui passe c'est pas bon ça fait
très mal
ils m'ont couche est interdit de bouger
amenés à manger pour pas que je bouge et
tout mais j'arrive dans mais c'est bon
la douleur elle va se passer pendant la
nuit il demain je re continue à vous y
avait d'autres étapes à faire en haute
montagne et à gigean je continue ou les
intérêts vécu et demain et donc je me
suis levé la nuit je crois vers 3 90 m
en hauteur pour aller tester en fait je
suis avec un peu de chance si je vois
que ça marche il j'ai mal ce sera qu'une
douleur donc ce sera moins de
l'interpréter correctement mais mais si
ça tient c'est bon quoi et
malheureusement c'est ressorti j'ai eu
le droit à une deuxième annulation j'ai
compris que j'ai besoin de sa présence
est clair ça fait partie non ça fait
partie de mes besoins permanents de
multi et de voir que je suis envie de
voir que je suis je suis encore capable
quel que soit le
de même que je suis opérationnel chez
chip en train de mon côté ça c'est hyper
satisfaisant en fait d'aller d'aller
chercher ces petites ces petites doses
de nalinnes comme ce à quoi je pense
avoir passé le cap de la diction pas du
besoin d'indépendance mais de
l'addiction mais il ya quinze ans de ça
je me revois travail et la revoit quand
je travaillais chez nice - et les 2 3h
4h du matin parce que parce que j'aime
ça je pense que je prends du plaisir il
meilleur à 23h59
j'ai pas fais ce sport est là faut que
j'allais le faire pour me dis que j'ai
fait mon sport aujourd'hui j'en ferai
demain c'est pas grave mais je me dis je
suis un vieux con que je voyais orange
aurait dû vivre à une autre époque en
fait ouais c'est j'ai beaucoup de mal
avec eux j'aurais ne pas été j'aurais de
pas internet web j'ai pas de temps enfin
j'ai pas de temps à perdre avec ça j'ai
un canapé chez moi mais je sais même pas
quelle forme il peut avoir en termes de
confort jamais vu un canapé je comprends
que autour de moi les gens visitent
charmant c'est pas c'est pas un problème
mais c'est pas la société dans laquelle
on vit et pas celles qui
ils matière j'ai instinctivement limite
c'est pas grave
en revanche j'ai plutôt tendance à dire
qu elle m'inquiète
si c'est elle si j'avais un accident si
j'étais paralysé si je croise pas
autrement je ferai des sports en
fauteuil sur l'espoir un vrai choix et
je sais pas mais je vais trouver
gg et puis ce sera pour moi le sont donc
il me reste un bras je m'amuserai faire
l'espoir car moi je sais pas lequel mais
je ferai les espoirs a clairement c'est
j aurai pas besoin de la performance
j'aurais juste besoin de me dire que
j'ai trouvé une solution en ont fait une
moins trois membres mais ils restent
inquiets qu'il valait mieux que je peux
faire quelque chose avec
[Musique]